let me ask you about love
um
what were some of the challenges what
were some of the lessons uh about love
about life that you learned from coming
out as gay hmm
in many ways it goes back to the stories
I think this is one of the
one of the reasons I became so
interested in stories and in their power
because I grew up in
um small Israeli town in the 1980s early
1990s which was very homophobic
um and I basically embraced it I I
breathed it
because the
you could hardly even think
differently
so you had these two powerful stories
around one that God hates gay people and
that uh he will punish them if if they
for who they are or for what they do
secondly that it's not God it's nature
that there is something diseased or sick
about it and these people maybe they're
not Sinners but uh they are they are
sick they are defective
and nobody wanted to identify with such
a thing if your options okay you can be
a sinner you can be a defect but what do
you want uh no good options there
and it took me many years till I was 21
to to come to term with it
um and one of the things I learned
through things first about the amazing
capacity of the human mind for denial
and delusion
that an algorithm could have told me
that I'm gay when I was like 14 or 15.
like if there is a good looking guy and
girl walking I would immediately focus
on the guy but I didn't I didn't I
didn't connect the dots
like I could not understand what was
happening inside my own brain and my own
mind in my own body
took me a long time to realize you know
you're just gay
so that speaks as a power of social
convention versus uh individual people
this is the power of self-delusion
that you know it's not that I knew I was
gay and was hiding it I was hiding it
for myself successfully that I I don't
understand how it is possible looking
back I don't understand how it is
possible but I know it is possible I
knew and didn't know at the same time
and then the other big lesson is the
power of of the stories of the social
conventions because the stories were not
true they did not make sense even on
their own terms even if you accept the
basic religious framework of the world
that there is a good god that created
everything and controls everything why
would a good God
uh punish people for love I understand
why a good God would punish people for
violence for hatred for cruelty but why
would God punish people for love
especially when he created them that way
so of uh so even if you accept the
religious framework of the world
obviously the story that God hates gay
people it comes not from God but from
Some Humans who invented this story they
take their own hatred this is something
humans do all the time
they hate somebody and they say no I
don't hate them God hates them
they throw their own hatred on God
and then if you think about the
scientific framework that said that all
gays that they are against nature they
are against the laws of nature that they
are and so forth
science tells us nothing can exist
against the laws of nature
things that go against the laws of
nature just don't exist there is a lot
of nature that you can't move faster
than the speed of light now you don't
have this minority of people who break
the laws of nature by going faster than
the speed of light and then nature comes
nah that's bad you shouldn't do that
that's not how nature works if something
goes against the laws of nature it just
can't exist
the fact that gay people exist me and
not just people you see homosexuality
among many many mammals and birds and
other animals it exists because it is in
line with the laws of nature
the idea that this is sick that this is
whatever it comes not from nature it
comes from the human imagination
some people or for whatever reasons
hated gay people they said oh they go
against nature but this is the story
created by people this is not the laws
of nature and this taught me
that so many of the things that we think
are natural or Eternal or Divine no they
are just human stories but these human
stories are often the most powerful
forces in the world
so what did you learn from your just a
personal struggle
of um
Journey Through the social conventions
to find one of the things that makes
life awesome which is love
so like how what it takes to kind of
strip away the self-delusion and the
pressures of social convention to wake
up it takes a lot of work a lot of
courage and a lot of help from other
people
you it's uh this kind of again heroic
idea that I can do it all by myself it
doesn't work
certainly with love you need at least
one more person
and I'm very happy that I I found it
sick who lived in the same small Israeli
town we lived on two adjacent streets
for years probably went to school on the
same bus for years without really
encountering each other in the end we
met on one of the first dating sites on
the internet for for gay people in
Israel in in 2002 you're saying the
internet works yes I you know I said a
lot of bad things or dangerous about
technology and the internet there are
also of course good things and this is
not an accident
you have two kinds of minorities in
history
you have minorities which are are a
cohesive group like Jews that yes you're
as small as being born Jewish in saying
Germany or Russia whatever you're born
in a small community but as a Jewish boy
you're born to a Jewish Family you have
Jewish parents you have Jewish siblings
you are in a Jewish neighborhood you
have Jewish friends
so these kinds of minorities they could
always come together and help each other
throughout history now another type of
minority like gay people or more broadly
lgbtq people
that as a gay boy you're usually not
born to a gay family with gay parents
and gay siblings and gain in a
neighborhood
um so usually you find yourself
completely alone
for most of History one of the biggest
problems for the gay community was that
there was no Community how do you find
one another
and the internet was a wonderful thing
in this respect because it made it very
easy for these kinds of diffuse
community so diffuse minorities to find
each other so me and it even though we
rode the same bus together to school for
years we didn't meet in the physical
world we met online because again in the
physical world you don't want to
identify in a Israeli town in the 1980s
you ride the bus you don't want to say
hey I'm gay is there anybody else gay
here that's not a good idea but on the
internet we could find each other
there's another lesson in there that
maybe sometimes the thing you're looking
for is right under your nose yeah a very
old lesson and a very true
lesson in in many ways so so you need
help from other people to to realize the
truth about yourself so of course in
love you cannot just love abstractly
there is another person there you need
to find them but also you know we were
one of the first Generations who enjoy
the benefits of Gay Liberation of this
very difficult struggles of people who
are much braver than us in the 1980s
1970s 1960s who dared to question uh
social conventions
to uh struggle at sometimes a terrible
price and we benefited from it
um and more broadly we spoke earlier
about the feminist movement there would
have been no Gay Liberation without the
feminist movement we also owe them
for you know starting to change the
gender structure of of the world
and this is always true you can never do
it just by yourself also I look at my
journey in meditation I could not have
found many I mean the idea of going to
Meditation Retreat okay
but I couldn't discover meditation time
I couldn't develop the meditation
technique by myself somebody had to
teach me this way of how to look inside
yourself
and
um I'm and it and it's also a very
important lesson
that you can't do it just by yourself
that this fantasy of complete autonomy
of complete self-sufficiency it doesn't
work you hear it it tends to be a very
kind of male match of fantasy I don't
need anybody I can be so strong and so
brave that I'll do everything by myself
it never works
me the friends you need a mentor
you need the very thing that makes us
human is other is other humans
absolutely